salut les menthe à l'eau il ya quelques
semaines on a eu le plaisir de recevoir
sur cette chaîne bernard werber qui nous
parlait de son nouveau spectacle et j'ai
eu aussi le plaisir en même temps de me
faire offrir son nouveau livre avant qui
sort j'ai fini de le lire et j'aimerais
bien vous en parler alors pour ça j'ai
contacté directement les éditions albin
michel pour qu'ils puissent nous envoyer
quelques exemplaires et que je puisse
vous les offrir vous explique tout ça à
la fin de la vidéo pour l'instant je
vous présente demain les chats générique
quoi oui j'écris le nouveau livre de
bernard werber est donc sorti hier
j'avais eu la chance de pouvoir
commencer à le dire en avance et je vous
le dis direct c'est une réussite
j'ai pas tellement envie de vous révéler
toutes les intrigues et de vous priver
des surprises que vous aurez en lisant
ce livre mais je vous dévoile pas grand
chose si je vous dis que par exemple le
point de vue principal est celui d'un
chat d'un chat fille donc c'est celui
d'une chatte intérêt de ce point de vue
c'est qu'on va découvrir toute la
société humaine selon le regard et le
mode de pensée d'un chat dans les
premières pages du livre je me suis dit
c'est original c'est ambitieux mais du
coup ce qui est original et ambitieux et
sûrement dure à mettre en place
en l'occurrence ça fonctionne très bien
mais au delà de l'histoire ce n'est pas
le seul point fort de ce roman pour moi
le vrai point fort c'est que bernard
werber s'inscrit comme un auteur
vraiment contemporain au sens littéral
du terme
le livre se passe réellement aujourd'hui
l'actualité qu'il ya dans l'histoire
nous rappelle la nôtre en permanence les
technologies qu'on cite dans l'histoire
est vraiment les technologies que
j'utilise moi au quotidien
j'avais eu cette impression comme ça de
réalisme de quotidiens quand j'avais lu
le livre le papillon des étoiles sam
lareau fait dans demain et chats et
quand j'ai terminé de le lire je me suis
dit mais en fait c'est quoi ce roman je
dirai au delà même de l'histoire de
l'intrigué c'est à ckoi demain les chats
je crois qu'on pourrait dire que c'est
une science fiction réaliste une espèce
de sf très moderne
je sais pas si c'est très clair ce que
je dis mais j'ai l'impression de lire du
jules verne de 2016 dans une certaine
mesure avec un traitement du suspense
aussi fort et aussi puissant que celui
que mais stephen king je pense que c'est
plus qu'un autre des romans de bernard
werber une autre sortie de livres je
pense que ce livre là c'est une espèce
de confirmation ce qui donne encore plus
envie de voir ce qui va écrire dans les
prochaines années et de lire ses futures
publications l'héroïne du livre ses
passes tête c'est elle je suppose en
tout cas excellent sur la couverture
elle va évoluer elle va jouer elle va
juger elle va essayer de comprendre
devoir essayer de communiquer avec tout
le monde des humains et on découvrir
au travers d'elle le père potentiel en
tout cas de ces enfants
son meilleur ami qui s'appelle pythagore
c'est un siamois c'est un siamois geek
est aussi fascinant que l'était le
véritable pythagore je vous remets un
lien vers la vidéo de la discussion que
j'avais eue avec bernard werber où nous
parle de pythagore et on sent vraiment
que le côté fascinant du personnage on
le retrouve dans le sirh moi et puis il
ya également la servante de bastet la
servante que nous dans notre langage on
appelle la maîtresse tout est une
question de point de vue
je vous recommande de lire de lâcheté de
vous le faire prêter de le prendre dans
une bibliothèque ou d'une médiathèque si
vous en avez l'occasion que vous ayez
déjà lu des livres ou pas de cette
hauteur là peu importe c'est une
histoire isolé des autres histoires
donc vous pouvez la commencer vous allez
tout de suite être kidnappée vous allez
tourner des pages comme ça tout le temps
avant d'aller plus loin je tiens à
préciser que ceci n'est pas un placement
de produit je n'ai pas reçu d'argent
pour ça j'ai pas été contacté pour ça je
comptais faire une vidéo dessus par
rapport à ce que j'avais déjà fait sur
la livre de bernard werber au début
d'année puis la conversation qu'on avait
de l'autre jour et j'ai eu un contact
direct avec albin michel pour recevoir
des livres pour vous parce que là je me
suis dit quitte à faire une vidéo dessus
si je peux leur faire gagner des il
s'écoule alors il m'a envoyé un coursier
et ce coursier m'amener non pas un
leader qu à la base c'était pour un
livre mes cinq exemplaires deux trois
cinq exemplaires pour vous tous
dédicacés par l'auteur et ça c'est
collector mon pote pour vous les faire
gagner je fais un tirage au sort la
dernière fois j'ai vraiment galéré la
semaine dernière pour le tirage au sort
vous m'avez envoyé quasiment 3000 mail
donc je me suis dit je vais le faire sur
les réseaux sociaux mais tout le monde
n'est pas connectée à tous les réseaux
sociaux donc c'est encore une galère
j'ai trouvé la solution ultime je vais
faire un google forme je vous mets le
lien dans la description vous rentrez
votre nom votre prénom votre mail tirage
au sort dimanche on va dire dimanche ça
vous laisse la semaine pour participer
et dimanche ferait une vidéo bonus en
plus de la vidéo du dimanche où je
filmerai directement le tirage au sort
avec tous les mails
est-ce que c'était bien clair ce que
j'ai dit c'est pas sûr il ya un lien
directement dans la description pour
participer au tirage au sort que je
ferai le 9 octobre
vous avez aussi peut-être remarqué que
j'ai commencé à modifier des choses sur
la chaîne j'en avais parlé fin août ça
arrive tout doucement gémit quand même
pas mal de choses aujourd'hui les plus
attentifs d'entre vous avez vu des
images subliminales traîner dans les
vidéos que j'avais fait ces sept
derniers jours
voilà il ya quasiment tous il manque
encore les nouvelles musiques et deux
trois petites choses mais je suis très
content de tout ça et le logo basse et à
force de lire vos commentaires que j'ai
fait ce logo la merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo je vous prépare quelque
chose de très très surprenant pour
demain 17h quelque chose que j'ai jamais
fait sur la chaîne que j'ai jamais fait
tout court d'ailleurs alors je sais pas
si ça va être du génie ou si ça va être
ridicule mais en tout cas ça va être
fait quoi qu'il arrive et ce sera inédit
sur cette chaîne n'oubliez pas de
soutenir la vidéo d'un pouce en l'air si
la vidéo vous a plu évidemment vous
pouvez également vous abonner avant de
partir si ce n'est pas déjà fait et
rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao